work has come to a halt for many in
Beirut but for fashion designer Tony
Ward who specializes in couture gowns
business is slowly picking up in a
different way as old musket
Emiliano Aquila was of inta Bangla we
first made these masks for our own
employees they can be worn in a very
simple way and also washed his garment
factory is shifting from its usual
production lines to helping local
hospitals by making masks body suits and
bedsheets - salois
they put me in contact with the director
of Rafiq Hariri Hospital and he told me
that they have a big shortage of
bedsheets because they're preparing a
new department we decided to buy fabric
involve our staff and work together to
make bed sheets as Lebanon's doctors and
nurses work on the front lines to
contain covered 19 private and public
hospitals are feeling the strain
there's not enough money and medical
supplies items that are normally
imported it's prompted other businesses
like this plants that usually makes
dental floss and diapers to step into
design ventilators women battle Mishka
maybe after this outbreak we will learn
a big lesson all Lebanese can have an
impact on the future present and their
reality not always depend on what's
coming from the outside and ask for help
Lebanon is already facing an economic
and financial crisis according to Human
Rights Watch the government has not
given any money this year to the
publicly funded Rafiq Hariri hospital in
Beirut where most cases are being
treated and it only gave 40 percent of
its Jews last year while infections
increase those running businesses like
this hope the vert input can help
prepare Lebanon for what may come Rahila
Mohammed Al Jazeera